I want oh you know what I didn't start
streaming on YouTube I'm a scrub that's
alright I'll fix it now it's been a long
day all really long day it's money yeah
I know but I've been up since 6:00 okay
hi guys you guys didn't see any of that
for all the people that saw it on
Twitter on YouTube
I mean switching Kings spot I apologize
hold on here I'm gonna run the intro
again okay so everyone saw that toys
except for the people on YouTube hi I'm
Eric that's John Luke doom via bar which
is $29.99 we're going to be playing on
the PlayStation VR headset as you can
see John with chasm I wish you guys a
game PIP $29.99 came out last Friday
sorry
here we go okay yeah he's gonna play on
controller first then we're gonna switch
over to the light gun but let's see how
this goes yeah John Lucas played like
five around three or five hours or more
than that no no I played about such a
bad light double this time but he's had
way more time than I have had with it so
the interesting thing with the doom VR
is that you're not really walking right
you're teleporting a lot
yeah just like teleportation the options
here okay I believe there is no walk
option at least here on the controller
layout which can't really seem to adjust
oh no there is less stick movement so
maybe actually I can okay wow that works
yeah okay you totally can move it's
really fast and I already feel like I'm
gonna vomit okay so let's just do the
teleporting then goo says hi today as
you robot friend I guess you're the
robot friend how's that feel really fast
really it look doesn't that fast I'm
like what I'm watching
okay like you're running do
like you're like man you know those um
like Disney rides where you're in like a
car and you're moving through like
really quick yeah like that okay so how
do you do glory kills in this in this
version so you teleport into the moat
does that get older that's still cool
that's still cool okay so the I'm
definitely gonna turn that off probably
from oh I don't even know there's a math
cool like 3d let's turn that off cuz
that is alright so you're not feeling
the the actual manual movement I can
maybe get used to it I've played enough
games with that like I played Skyrim
that way a bit and I played all of
Resident Evil that way yeah actually
didn't bother me I think I have a weird
iron stomach when it comes to VR yeah I
would say you do so it's definitely the
way to the way they do fall in it right
I mean if you get used to the
teleporting it does kind of channel the
speed of doom you know so like all right
here we go I'm gonna look at chat so
there's a couple of cool things this
does well one if you notice in the top
the compass it actually shows the camera
where is yeah which is good because when
you're playing it it's very easy to kind
of like get disoriented and all of a
sudden you're like facing this way yeah
and then because of the way psvr works
you can't really gotta kind of be in
front of you right yeah like you can
easily all of a sudden gets janky so
like being able to say like oh I need to
reorient myself it's actually kind of
nice like I kept doing that with Skyrim
and I wish Skyrim had that maybe it does
and I just didn't notice but I need to
recheck that but that seemed cool yeah
and I think to my knowledge when I
looked up Skyrim it was like full price
which is like and that's that is just
skyress this is like his own thing
around
you're not playing as the do marine
you're playing it was like a dude who
like died and is put in this like robot
chassis basically he talks it's kind of
weird I don't really care for his
dialogue okay he's it's sort of whatever
how's the grenade launcher oops I I just
got it when I stopped so I actually
don't really know it's called the bfg
grenade launcher what Jeff which is
seems a little ridiculous bunch of
minigames into this yeah how's this it's
it's super whatever they're like very
basic mini-games they don't give you
later is in that prototype hyper demon
they lost take advantage of the VR so
I'm kind of it's kind of weird that
during this game this is cool like you
know this is an environment from the
first game yes Hayden's office and I'll
be able like look at that were you doing
the oh so you are doing the kind of
toggle turn that Skyrim kind of has to
right yeah so you can kind of do this to
a jóska in addition to this do you feel
like that's a pretty good yeah I think
so because they said that was to kind of
help with the nausea - I think it does
kind of like the I would say like maybe
45 degree yeah I mean the because you
don't have that full 360 the way you
would with like a vibe by the way this
game is on five we have a code for it I
haven't had a chance to measure it but
I'm curious how that version fares fares
all right try to hit fun sometimes a
little finicky because you don't you're
not able Blake precisely stand where you
want to all the time with the teleport
okay
so I'm playing with the controller and
when you do that you aim with the
headset
okay just how you did it in Resident
Evil and I actually really liked that
it's super precise like like I'm able to
easily headshot demons and that actually
feels really cool
except for that guy who the secret
epistles nod let's go to uh okay with
that yeah I mean like even just before
that before he had mentioned that I was
like okay he's nailing most of these
shots so that's pretty good that
actually feels really good it felt
really good in resonable as well and
that's something where I would actually
love to compare it to uh oh
I shoulda killed him I would love to
compare it to like a mouse and keyboard
in terms of accuracy like which is more
accurate because it's probably
shockingly accurate they I guess well
because I you think about it like as
humans we naturally like over the good
at moving our heads to like look at
things right so it's it feels really
natural to just like aim with your head
alright a little baby by the punch
little baby punch
yeah I did kind of put don't leave on a
spot a little bit today like hey I know
you're playing June VFR the other day
what are your thoughts of streaming that
I wound up and the first thing I saw was
a text in fact come on I want that sweet
glory kill Oh get out of there
so I have a button where I can like do
like a one six each one of these okay oh
yeah do you actually like see the
giblets when you're in VR there oh yeah
all right that's pretty cool oh there's
that berserk you can save it for later
oh yeah all right uh yeah if you guys
have questions uh I or Gallatin chat oh
here we go we're just gonna breeze ERK
everything nice
revenant yep see you later if you guys
have questions hit me up on the chat and
I will do my best to get to John Luther
the questions you have yeah split about
an hour-and-a-half which is more than I
have played obviously
Wow berserk is doing work right oh yeah
I like it completely now we're good okay
now I just heard some animal like you
know demon noises so one thing that this
also has that other games don't is on
the d-pad you actually do like a little
quick like oh my gosh yes yeah you don't
want to use it for like moving obviously
but it's good in combat when you're like
oh I need a dodge of this projectile to
the left of the right really quick yeah
so it's actually pretty smart I think
that's the kind of good way to handle
that yeah cuz the combat is it's still
pretty fast-paced Mario account wasn't
know about the grenade launcher is just
something you have that they added into
VR I guess right yes yeah it's just like
a grenade launcher I might be the same
model of the grenade launcher they added
in the multiplayer because they added
some weapons to the multiplayer it might
be the same I don't remember a steam
account asking what's the fov like so
right now it's kind of weird like the
gun is like very like like the shotguns
like this it feels a little bit off I
don't know Oh like we're the actual good
you could turn off a lot of the HUD
elements too which is cool
okay feels okay though just for reason
that shotguns way too close and I want
to be oh he knows the co-op ELO's sorry
if I butchered your name there and says
love you too guys thank you oh thanks
I think zukie TV asking can you turn on
full motion motion I assume they mean
like moving like me well not on psvr if
that's what you mean
paka a wolf there is joystick movement
but John Luke wasn't necessarily a fan
of it something I think you gotta get
used to I could get used to it all right
okay so the sex area actually died a
bunch all right well you better not see
how I do
Oh didn't get comped you to the next
mission okay this is gonna be a little
trial by fire so don't tell yourself
short okay yeah and in like I don't know
20 minutes or so we'll try using the but
god the gun and I'm gonna get out of the
way because he's gonna be full-on and I
don't want to get hit in the face or
maybe I do I don't know
alrights how you doing this so no I
doubt a bunch it'll be fine so I think
well I will talk about molana traffic
gun but for me I think this feels way
better to play like more accurate with
the controller because I have a much
better sense of like when I'm shooting
then the gun the gun okay but the gun
probably is like a better immersive
experience yeah because like you're
holding on to it
yeah ooh
what well there there we go that was
weird
yeah doing work what's easy again I
wonder let me try this I was running
with the gun so I actually wonder if
that's maybe part of it well like you
said feels more active for you guys
there's way more accurate
oh yeah let me get that music in all of
these it's good it's still boom take
your plate dodge the controller gaming
in this time yeah I don't know if they
recorded any new tracks it sounds all
the same that's fine man I'm okay with
that
who's complaining about that hot dude
2700 2016 soundtrack of the year
I'm curious how this is the watch oh
sorry I should I should be watching the
stream version no it looks pretty good
okay I'm worried I'm like moving my head
too much oh I mean you just gotta do you
at anyone that's gonna get sick it's
just gonna get sick right i apologies in
advance
bernard baker asking do you feel like
you are in a do in doom or playing a
game oh I definitely feel like I'm
playing a game okay but I do think you
know I'm like most ER games
it is cool to like I just think the game
moves so quickly like I'm not really
appreciating
oh yeah pistol yeah yeah yeah pistol oh
yeah get that rocket launch yeah
smoke some of these stupid demons yeah
you can I think it doesn't actually I
thought it I think it looks fine prophet
regret yeah he says he thinks it looks
awful I think it looks good I mean so
one thing you gotta understand is uh
resolution you guys have seen who's
actually lower than what the headsets
have little that's true so it'll
actually look a little bit worse
outputted than it will in the game
that's not to say the game looks like
you know obviously the vibe version
looks significantly better right you
know less anti-aliasing a jagged but I
mean it runs a really serious and
honestly it first psvr I think it looks
pretty good
is this just doom in VR hurt or have
they changed much yeah
and it's not just the doom campaign it's
and so an original campaign which is
pretty cool I think you'd have to do it
that way I don't if you can just take
that campaign
all right so we need I should have saw
that coming
yeah give him that grenade launcher but
that's so off no he's desert oh yeah I
mean at least that one mate say I mean
[ __ ] a wolf the thing is at least do one
vibe Wood is only 29.99 so I mean I
would say that's not bad if you're on
the fence forgetting it but you know
they're ballers feel $30 I feel like
this is probably worth second out
yeah this is going better because it
killed two of those guys I'm the big guy
in the middle so too long to goopy rice
says ha J at John Luke how do you feel
wearing that VR helmet for long periods
of time I think as mentioned earlier
John Liu oh well I'm speaking for him
but he's got the iron stomach for it so
I feel like PE of all people could
probably keep it all along yeah the big
thing for me is more just my eyes like
the strain of my eyes and I don't know
if that's a combination of like the
screen being on your head and maybe the
resolution a little bit low like it's a
little blurry in spots isn't the big guy
show up now oh wait this is a new
campaign so it'd be a yeah yeah I have
no idea this is the I've not gotten this
far so we'll find out for ourselves
oh hello there this looks familiar
I'm a little out of every oh there was a
moan that other oh here you go and his
armor there here will power up
and obviously if you're gonna be playing
VR you want to be able to be able to
stomach it and if you can't then VR is
probably not for you yet yeah weird
actually watching you kind of like
almost ingest that tape or disk well you
put shaving cream on his head since you
can't see you right now
demon that's how immersive VR
experiences like I throw buckets of
water at you when you glory kill
something because it's just like all
right if he's switching the gun I'm
getting out the way if you want to
actually get D I could turn that sucker
up sorry Oh slightly off screen you can
go to the right a bit so you got all the
real estate he'll just be here yeah
you're good you're right in the middle
now you got all the space I'll just be
over here trying to read chat quickly
switch to it for demon escaped okay so
all right wait no I need to point at the
camera that's the only thing I'm not
okay so the camera is right there oh
well you can see it on your radar thing
I might need to adjust it okay all right
you do you the facility I found what the
gun can get a little weird
let's let's see if I can BFG prototypes
yeah see it's kind of freaking out right
now okay what do you want to do then I'm
trying to fix it we need to do it see if
I can get this work I make sure they
still work a little test fire as he
would say
okay that seems it seems okay yeah sure
okay
no man I stand up a little better hey do
you want me to put the camera down
yeah what the camera back a little bit
yeah that's much better okay so here we
go this is actually kind of cool because
it does feel like you have the weight of
a gun on you so what I'm looking at like
the shotgun it does feel like I'm
actually holding like this double-barrel
and that's pretty cool but you lose some
of the accuracy yeah with the controller
of the controller but yeah like that's
the trade-off right yeah
oh well this in the normal game is where
you would have got to be FG exactly okay
so I might be getting something you have
to related don't you have to be FG
grenade launcher that's what I thought
but I guess maybe this is just a regular
grenade launcher and I will pick up the
BFG grenade launcher
that was the power conditioner I'm gonna
need a replacement you need to get back
to operations okay
guess I'm going somewhere so you can do
kind of cool stuff this like I can pick
up like these throttles and kind of look
at them but that's kind of a battle
spear perch in the ravines surprise this
stuff goes I guess I can pick i'm just
start there I don't know how to pick
these other ones though well just get
out sweet
how far away from you or you could swing
bet yeah they're pretty far away I'm
totally off cam you cannot sweep yeah
I'll play the dodging game Chris Jose I
don't know if you're serious or not but
I'll ask it anyways why does Xbox not
have a VR any games well they're gonna
have their own Microsoft wallet they're
owned by Microsoft right okay what's up
has hololens
right so there's that could be part of
it yeah that's much more prototype right
now I'd say BAM
well hard to say why they're not getting
into it Oh does that work gun but like I
did like I'd want to be like in the head
smack them like that right it totally
doesn't owe you got the Gauss cannon
yeah but it's like the basic version
oh we're guns kind of freaking out a
little bit what what hey gun oh good
and so the gun freaking out it's more
indicative of our power setup right now
we're set up I wouldn't necessarily put
that on the game as far as it freaking
out that's more like we I should be
further back well here's to back then
hold on okay okay mess up this whole
room take
okay yeah yeah see it's it's [ __ ] I just
hate the computer no we're good we're
good
thank you for one day I got a trophy I
don't know why but you get it I did
something oh hello there
yeah so as many people in China
mentioned you can you can just move
normally but generally prefers the the
teleporting and sort of okay that's
sweet hell I do like the 180 thing
though that's good but one anything
having the 180 buttons pretty clutch oh
wow
okay right in the legs
okay let's try bacon plays I think X
just got a nice cool well happy that
you're out of school and tuning in with
us thank you
okay so yeah now I'm moving free seems
to be kinda like the gun kind of freaks
out when you do it if you want oh yeah
it's kind of like yeah the gun so he's
in full motion now the gun doesn't full
motion but he's controlling it just
normally with the stick guy teleport
there's a shielded guy back here
bad news isn't it oh you live somehow oh
boy does he not enjoy nausea no he
doesn't get nauseous so this is great
not as much or as I have to be careful
how much I watch the screen so I look at
chattering ah and then it feels good
we'll try this a little bit but it
definitely feels Wolff jankier
especially with the way they've done
kind of behavior
but I do feel like I I'm able to kind of
like react
[Music]
Kyle delima I think do you find the
teleporting noise to help lessen the
nausea of warp removing the noise yeah
Oh actually freaked me out when you
looked down yeah long fall someone's up
close actually have pretty bad fear of
heights but that didn't really freak me
out it's not okay I thought it would it
just made me like a little anxious even
though I wasn't playing for whatever
reason
unfortunately mega rocket 99 we haven't
tried the five version we do have it so
unfortunately we can't compare it I
guess it would be that it would be a
slightly graphically would slightly at
least be Oh graphically definitely and
I'm sure you have yep you know with the
five you have the ability actually kind
of like dodge that way which would
probably be at least a better the arts
crimson black Esmond I don't know if he
just started to tune in but he is using
the normal movement controls now but
he's just he just got used to the
teleporting more so than the normal
movement but kind of
some of it here oh no I guess is that so
what are your kind of impressions I'll
let you take care of this guy okay
what are your kind of impression so far
with just VR in like 2017 I guess I'm
just I'm personally still not sold I
think we're like we we've slowly gained
a little bit of momentum here but not
really yeah that's kind of if this was
sort of the year were a lot of the big
like triple a you know franchises
started to put out stuff Resident Evil
Skyrim now Jews and at least for me I
found probably Resident Evil to be the
most impressive better preserve I just
remember Nick going through this part I
mean going like come on Nick grab the
berserk please I don't know what that is
or quad I will do a Nick did not yes
please
oh there's armor there let's keep going
waste of a berserk I think you're really
some of it come on don't waste it like
it has been wasted bummer
where's a dude screaming maybe behind in
that room before I'll see
this way a little secret is that rock
music that's cool
yeah resident Ville is probably my
favorite experience and I think it's
actually pretty impressive how they
manage to whoa this is weird because it
feels way lighter than its a jig gun
like you could show with one hand like
the double of the double barrel shotgun
actually like this feels like oh this is
probably how heavy it would
approximately be this feels like oh this
is kind of weird
mm-hmm Nacala same want to make good VR
games let me control it with the effing
ps4 controller uh I mean as John Luke
just mentioned yes I mean if you're
talking about the standard psvr
controller PS controller yeah you can do
that yeah you can do that with this one
you can also do it with Resident Evil as
well I think it's the only way to
actually to play Resident yeah you don't
have to teleport guys it's just a choice
yeah okay totally not teleporting right
now but teleporting is the easiest way
to not get sick which is why default
they default to the options that will
get people to leave sick you like I sold
it like this
get to the choppa that's okay that's
kind of cool
this games got some cool stuff in it
Kyle not as big of a fan of this on VR
as much as he is for like Skyrim because
of the open world or the creepy house
rd7 sure I understand that I mean I
think Styron's sort of like that when
you think of like when people imagine
like oh the future of video games in VR
I think people considered a game like
Skyrim right where it's like oh it's a
massive open world that you can explore
in virtual reality but that game I think
has problems just by being a six year
old game that has been built from the
ground up to incorporate VR the way like
Resident Evil 7 feels like it's more
smartly incorporates that stuff for this
game which is really where my problems
with Skyrim VR kind of live somewhere I
think jtt is and can you use a PS aim
controller and the Move controller at
the same time Oh like the movie Move
controller I don't know if you can use
the Move controller I actually haven't
tried it okay well we wanted to know if
you could use I guess the aim and the
move at the same time but I don't see
why you would want to I mean this thing
has like stuff on here so really it's
like you this up a particular reason to
mega rocket 99 saying 3d effects are
stronger with closer objects so
corridors are actually pretty cool in VR
yeah no I agree like that's the thing
with Skyrim is you look it out and
you're like that is a beautiful blurry
Vista while like up close objects like
they have a little bit more of like a
cool VR punch to them
Kyle Deline we're asking do you feel
like you are on Mars to an extent like
you felt like you were in the Baker
house yeah totally
I do I just think that that game is
really slow so you gotta get to that
game like encourages you to really like
take your time and walk around that
house and look at all the detail this
game you're moving at a pretty fast pace
so I don't think you get to appreciate
it
wait as much but I think it still
captures that based on the minigun is
just awesome yeah it's pretty sweet got
in school mega rocket 99 saying you
can't use the aim and move controller to
save time yeah it's kind of what I
figured I wish you could rip demons
apart with the motion patrol Karass
sensei asking can you reduce movement
speed in settings this looks fast faster
than I expected I see a dial to change
the movement speed but you were saying
the same thing which was that it was
kind of fast but it's either like a turn
on or turn off I think segments turning
turn about but that's that's so that's
how much the camera turns when hit the
right stick there doesn't seem to be a
left stick movement so this doesn't look
like it like you can cuz there and it
does move really fast and I think now
it's gonna make a lot of people feel
very comfortable like I'm already
getting more used to it than I was
initially
but the thing for me is that like when I
stand it's fine but then the second I
move the way that gun starts like that I
find coming off that breaks it up a
little bit
let's say you're almost done with this
mission probably oh yeah
good work good work
thank you gave it goin yeah yeah Skyrim
I would love to I would love to see what
someone's experiences like playing like
a lot and putting a lot of time in
Skyrim you know I didn't put as much as
I don't put like a couple hours in but
you're enjoying it though I was enjoying
for the most part it's funny like
there's certain janking this to that
game like when you just do this like
yeah wave your hand around like a like
you're like you have a wand in your hand
but you have a dagger and you're just
like killing someone just like flailing
your wrist the two-handed swords like in
the game you know the animation speeds a
lot slower to make up for their you know
more damage but with VR it's like
they're the same weight so you can just
swing it just as fast as anything else
and that kind of feels a little bit
weird so you almost sort of act like
role play a little bit in that sense
right like pretend it's heavy and slow
exactly right it's just like a little
weird no you just do what you want you
make it like a it's like as strong as a
two-handed sword but as fast as just
like using a tree branch
ghost played I think 6v6
it's the same game I mean are there
different levels no it's not the same
game as doom it's kind of Kaunas it's
got its own campaign
yes environments for sure but not 100%
like that area we were just in is
obviously using similar assets but it is
a completely different you know well
this is actually just rate up like the V
of T testing
simultaneous blasts for the prototypes
mega rocket 99 saying I put 20 hours
into Skyrim VR it's really awesome and
doesn't make me feel nauseous at all
yeah I mean I played all of VR and
control center I thought that was an
amazing way that experience like yeah it
kind of helps to in that in Skyrim VR
that it has kind of that vignette when
you're like during like movement and
whatnot because then it kind of helps
focus like you're what you're looking at
I guess so that you don't get as keep
you from getting nauseous by darkening
the edges yeah Resident Evil does that
as well and it Resident Evil it actually
works even better because that game is
already so dark they actually don't even
notice though it was half the time we're
like Skyrim it still does it's not like
an immersive breaking thing because you
like you said you are kind of focusing
more in the middle but definitely like
if you look at it you know on a bright
day in Skyrim you can see it while is in
Resident Evil main free it's really dark
the whole time so it's fine ooh now it's
green oh it's like a different goodnight
what it might be this now like city of
to sweet
oh there's whoa it's good snow but
you're out of that ammo or are you know
I got to I don't want to yeah I don't
want to waste that wasted that's kind of
insane that they just give you that but
all right I guess I could take their
liberties sure yeah the idea that we
just put a BF genes in cilantro for me
just pick up their weird oh yeah
it's more anyway
yeah there he goes I am I don't know I
will say like just like just Bob your
head while your music I know I don't
know if it's just because I'm visually
seeing the gun in your hand but it does
look like a as you had mentioned earlier
the more immersive exchange just kind of
having the gun in hand
what is the comparative just having a
controller aim oh it definitely does
yeah for sure it feels more murder feels
like it's the way you should sort of
play it by your accuracy does happen
it's probably a better you really want
that VR experience hi ma'am oh that's
pretty fast
yeah
[Music]
yeah mega rocket 99 also saying for me
the snap turning helps to stop nausea
which is also in Doom VFR yep most games
have it it's kinda best way to handle it
I would love to see because I think what
the Resident Evil people said was that
it was just like a timed exclusive
license deal for psvr
so we're coming up to the one-year
anniversary of that game they can
theoretically
I guess put it out on like five oculus
as well and I would actually love to
replay that again with those headsets
with like the increased like resolution
and you know potentially like more to do
I think that would actually be really
really cool I would especially love to
play that game with like an actual like
I can aim the gun as opposed to the head
cuz it's like you said like it was
really accurate when I played a
resonable 7 the headset actually made
the game a lot easier cuz I was just
able to headshot significantly easier
than I could with a controller but
that's the game where the immersion such
a big deal that actually being able to
have like a go but I'm shooting would be
pretty cool probably making more like
nerve-wracking to that gave me a BFG and
you got another there's another one so
you could essentially shoot one of the
shots here because there's gonna be a
there's gonna be enough there you see
that ammo right like above right there
that's another TX we shot I think that's
what's down there okay oh that may be a
buff that's a nice bow
I try remember with the green one I
can't remember a baby honest Purple's
Quad Squad yellow
yeah I think you need to you say you
need yeah
that work
yeah has some micro missiles one of my
favorite like attachment okay
I'm curious now but I'm gonna try
something okay see if it still works
wait for more deets to show up
oh I saw it can can tell see what I was
trying to do was vulnerability I would
have been nice all right well whatever
what I was trying to do was in the
original game and I don't think they
patched it the way the BFG works is it
does like area of effect damage and but
when you slow down with holding the
weapon wheel it slows down the the
projectile but it doesn't actually slow
down the amount of damage it's doing so
you can use it to cheese bosses and beat
them in like two seconds
oh wow what speed runners use and I was
curious if that effect was still in play
here what is locked at 25% I shall be
able to access the overlies from the
mainframe control center
nope check give me just one second I
feel like today was one of those days
where I may very well have put the wrong
contact in each eye which is making my
chat very blurry for me to read oh no
I'm gonna try to Remy up here we go and
see if that's the case that might not be
the case
do not shoot Oh what are the odds secret
look at that hey hey there
come on a little finicky call that
elevator
Oh
I'm not still seeing this right hmm no
maybe not
I mean the thing is kind of pointing
that way this is the way I can bow this
is the way I came
oh I see I see
I'm sorry sorry I'm being not useful to
you because that's like I'm sorry guys
first time playing this area I'm just
trying to kind of figure it out all
right there we go yeah so we want the
security overrides are accessible from
the mainframe control
[Music]
all right I can see I think except my
right eye hurts really bad right now
hold on oh yeah you could check your map
I could check my map as people were
right too late now though forget lost in
the future doc I actually can't tell if
that actually helped my visit hits the
button ah Jesus
yeah sometimes I hit these buttons a
little today you can't just shoot it
yeah there we go okay it's been a little
weird that'd be cool dude just shot it
to open it it says return to player am I
not pointed up there use your BFG though
yeah so the cameras start to freak out
again I'm wondering if I'm not in the
right spot
how's that did that help it seems better
yeah there we go now I can use this
elevator
why is a left gun in your hand constant
that's just the thing that they have
yeah it's the gun that shoots the
grenade and it's also the one that Wow
it doesn't do it here and when you're
using the controller it's also the one
that aims the teleport yeah it's just a
weird constant it's a little janky I
agree it looks kind of weird-looking
Ariyoshi remember any area like this oh
yeah that's pretty neat like a testing
area I like it how much good this stuff
is like stuff that was probably in the
game and then just never
yes come on reuse those assets okay oh
no you just probably went shooting in
the past
whoa that was kind of weird so there
right yeah his left gun is now BFG it
used to be just a grenade launcher but
it's just kind of get that in the game
nice little like thing to have get out
of the way others even business
boom always kind of like those
challenges
it made me try to like get more glory
right and things like that
Oh get B of g'd think got the big guys
you in the air well the Gauss was about
precision
oh yeah B if that that's pretty
satisfying just to see is fine you got a
bunch more you can pick up I think
there's one tier below there somewhere
it feels like paper yeah there we load
that B of GMO now that you have it I
almost want them to send like more
demons at you just so you can have
because now that you have the BFG also I
feel like I'm havin actually needs your
time with the movement oh now it's doing
it just like normal movie nice that
teleport yeah now that I like know how
it cuz I can use both basically it's
like it's kind of nice because it just
gives me the option to use both Bruce
who's row game does this game feel scary
at all with a headset or not really do
you feel any tension real tension not
particularly but the game it's not
really trying to scare you I mean the
dunes up close are pretty gnarly looking
but Resident Evil definitely scared me a
couple times for sure that game is
freaky with the headset on
well this game it's not really trying to
steer yeah I can see some people getting
freaked out though yeah I remember that
now they made you too happy to use that
I remember this area I did - oh it's
probably a waste I was gonna say man
you're uh you're using some heavy-duty
weaponry on some of these lower tier any
types it's gonna get pretty bad here
soon
how dessous that's how it was doesn't
feel as accurate I still feel like I'm
able to aim fairly accurately with this
like it's pretty fun this is it's very
fun to use the gun huh
I don't know much the gun cost I can
find I don't know if you buy it
separately or if it's like a VR I know
it came as a bundle with them Farpoint
teleport I remember this area this is
cool Wow
aim controller $60 59.99 I guess you
could have bought it with PowerPoint I
don't know if there's a VFR buy there is
a doozy if our bundle I don't know if it
comes with a head okay or if it comes a
big good the PlayStation you could get
it with fond damage nice if you get a
power point and the gun for 80
huh does that look cool cool yeah oh
there goes the legs
doing work are you enjoying this more
than v12 it yes I had to throw it out
there yeah I was running actually I was
gonna come up cuz that big big I don't
know I think I would probably rather
play this than she wants which do after
playing it I mean I hope this is also a
different experience which was just lose
30 bucks if this is 30 instead of 16
which I still find insane but whatever
that's just me right like it's cheaper
to buy this than it is to buy DuPont's
which I believe yes yeah I'm curious if
anyone in the audience actually picked
up psvr over Black Friday they had a lot
of really good bundles going for it that
were like really cheap and I kind of
actually thought about it for like a
moment uh-huh I hated these the witches
I ended up not because at least so far
any time I really want to play VR I can
play it here yeah so I think that just
kind of kept me from maybe wanting to
put down the money to play at home plus
my head my house is already kind of
getting full
[Music]
fine yeah the fundal does not excuse me
the bundle does not have the aim the
doors the gun okay but you'd have to buy
that for a sixty flow pistol of lat oh
not okay their health up there somewhere
hell yeah there we go whoa whoa you're
cool so if you find that which again you
could probably just give her the
business like that yep
yeah there's a couple of pretty good oh
no in the normal game I remember that at
some point that one of it's fine but
yeah there was some I don't know there's
some decent Black Friday deals I I'm
probably gonna get a PS pro bundle at
some point it's kind of waiting for my
friend to see if he wants to keep an eye
on that pageant got one he said for 200
what
well apparently you also like traded in
Oh his old ps4 Xone ps4 he got a pro for
like 200 right now you good 54 Pro
bundle I saw a deal where there was one
going over the weekend it was going for
like 3 20 yeah it's pretty good sweet
cherry nope sweet cherry are looking at
this why not alien isolation VR they
technically had a version it was sorta
like save the BFG ammo but I'll just
kill him with it yeah I know you went
ham with it earlier and I could have
saved it for the harder part of that one
room ya know I've actually played a
really nice that was actually my first
VR experience in isolation that games
pretty freaky it was freaky it was
really cool that is my first thing in VR
that's all they did a good job with that
one again you had like narrow corridors
and
like kind of see yourself getting them
killed if you got caught the best wasn't
Danny was like looking down his chest
and liked it a little like
the tale of the alien had gone through
chess I have a really good video of my
friends trying it and he does not like
horror games and he was just saying not
have a good how did he even get how did
you even convince him to do it we were
doing it for extra life so that's how we
convinced him it was like a goal like
hey we'll make him play it if you hear
this sir exactly
these guys are annoying yeah well you
pretty much have to hope for them to
charge
[Music]
that's correct come on a few minutes but
yeah now's work yeah there we go it's
fine just just mainly save those ammo
for the big swarm of guys that you end
up having to deal with later
the Persian gamer said I think I just
got sold going to get the game now enjoy
it alright I want you to finish this
yeah and then if that will be I will
call it there yeah all right cool or you
just keep doing it to you I feel like
I'm actually probably pretty far in this
yeah I was gonna say like I feel like
you might be getting to that point
nice work you're gonna save the quad for
that
ya crazy little fun a lot I use it too
early
so yeah just let us lorry kill you
oh yeah oh I don't think he finished him
that was awkward
did I not I don't think so I can tell ya
there is
work as a wall all right now those
stupid shield guys I like to you it was
in a wall
no reason to be necessarily standing Bob
for this it's kind of a point of regard
I think you can stand but there's it
also works very fine without a headset
or with sitting down there we go
yeah you're like nah not this time wait
messing around rich stupid witch all
right where they at John Luke you got
all the damage in the world yeah how's
it feel
you got ammo what do you have left
Oh Rockets good
oh yeah pfg is also good
do about it do do did we do
maybe oh you tell me you're the one
that's in the game sweet call the
elevator see if that's the actual end Oh
I want to see some ducking and dodging
philanthropy that soundtrack I love it
so much
oh oh oh no there's a big gap oh you say
this is exactly how it was in like the
base game oh I'm so terrible with the I
just know this guy oh there's two of
them yeah a VFD so kind of make that
trivial a little bit all right that
works I'm not gonna take it away with
you from you though Oh imagine if he
didn't have to be empty though I know
doing pretty screwed I feel like I did
right
going into hell and doom via fire but
you know well we'll see well okay fine
we'll see what your next mission yes if
it's hell we'll go through hell that
seems fair
why do you have a second gun and why
aren't you using it so the second gun
Carlos pass the last quiz starts as a
grenade launcher but we have now
upgraded it to a b FG and so he's using
it sparingly because he only has three
shots and obviously you want to make
your b FG count impact like in that case
he smokes too really hard demons just
because he had the beauty so let's see
if we end up going to hell that contains
just a means to be configured to
stabilize them that's my that's my dad
dude it's you yeah
all right that's okay sure it's a bit
weird all right so what are you doing
this is like a weird puzzle thing you do
know okay don't make a pentagram
way to solve that puzzle Baron of hell
thank you serious fair enough hell yes
they are
there it is what help portal oh yeah
sweet well we got to keep going right
yeah we got to lose a loan I got do a
little bit of hell it's just black
fellas black who wouldn't
let's get loading screen Oh
maybe nope this is where that expedition
landed in hello there I don't have time
to appreciate multi-verse mom I think
how does it feel with the aim controller
done it's fun yeah as he had said
earlier I think we're done we had said
earlier it isn't necessarily as precise
as a controller but it's still pretty
pretty good it's pretty precise still
and it's really fun whoa that felt weird
hi this is cool
so yeah we have made it to hell we're
just gonna I'll wait a sec for that we
sure as hell will
is there turning with the aim controller
or does it still rely on you there's
like a button for you to kind of turn
yeah you can use the less the right
stick yeah you could turn your head as
well see it that it no not like this
oh come on that skull
it's a trap it is I don't remember how
to well this is new and different there
you go
do we have smooth turn enabled oh come
on why would you try that do we have a
smooth turning anything smooth turning
enabled why did you go under it I was
trying to teleport on top of it trying
to showboat yeah it was dumb
let me still want me redo it
[Music]
okay coq10 streaking out
there we go
okay well I need to fix this gun let's
also check the settings because they
were asking about what are they asking
about smooth smooth turning it might not
look smoothing yeah it's at 90%
Oh aim assist is on okay that makes
sense as far as aiming for the is there
snap turning enabled stop turning yeah
okay stop turning is what you do with
okay guns fixed
show me more of help
Yeah right but oh dude it wasn't this in
the face came to you I remember this
room this room suck oh yeah
talk about luck of the draw there that
was awesome yeah this is pretty cool
looking this is doing a pallet the Lima
asked me do you know if the No More
Heroes DLC for re 7 is gonna be playable
in VR ah I believe so there were some of
the some of their DLC so some DLCs were
not available in VR and some were I bet
you that one is and I would actually
love to try that to go into that seem
like there's always end one gonna be fun
pretty soon I'm actually really excited
please what is that next week okay will
be if I get you on a stream that's er
well unless and I think it comes out
during their a game of the year stuff
though so what to figure that out
oh yeah best of the year sorry I keep
calling game of the year the game of the
year is the actual game of the year but
best of the year as you guys if you guys
didn't know we're doing best of the year
next week we're gonna count down our top
10 games of the year coming from 10 all
the way to 1 10 through 4 will be just
individual games each day and then the
last study would be 3 to 1 will be the
last on one day
[Music]
I am NOT firing my gun my bullets that's
the night of 12 but I'm not firing any
of them nope nope no nice
now on
he's like stuck feel like a rocket that
Ezard were you trying to shoot the BFG
yeah was just trying to use it yeah it
definitely looked like your time here we
go whoo duck hunt where's that damn dog
I don't know if you guys can notice it
but it's kind of funny because I see
gently trying to dodge the bullets with
his head yeah I know I know I'm sure I
would be doing it too but it's just like
as a person that has the outsider
perspective yeah you got for life this
FYI oh I'll give you one more shot let's
finish this one opportunity let's finish
this a room and then I think we should
call it here all right sounds good
vengeance will be yours oh my guns uh
freaking out again we're gonna have your
hands got rocket punch hand like in
Metal Gear that was actually one of
those funny
it's kind of an easter egg right now it
was like sea or a secret I guess how to
fix this just kind of eventually because
I should be right
is it good or Dean you fix it now it's
definitely not good okay hit throw it
back there yeah let me just uh put it
back there for you uh here
well the camera is this way Oh slightly
to your left now yeah how the ghost is
gone weird
are you try doing it this way it'll be a
terrible but Oh nothin fix itself okay
sure
all right a little drink here we go
[Music]
yeah that's that a thing is pretty
clutch the 180 180
[Music]
then why rocket hands that's right possi
yeah you won hitting it it's fun it's
funny one ampere the shotgun it's like
it's like Terminator 2 or you're just
one hand reloading it yeah and then you
like flip it yeah I can try that it's
like no I can't that this gun is too
[Music]
like a 58 health
[Music]
pretty sure some nasty stuff see a
likely spot to where is he
forget that are tomorrow later
instead oh boy how bad do you want the
armor big effing gun him too I can't I
don't know how oh you can't I'm not sure
what oh is it not allowing oh don't have
like it does have a different like
weapon modifier on it now looks more
like that I don't know yeah I'm not sure
if I hit a button but the icon looks
different than what it was before
one-handed Rob hunter
oh yeah give it boo okay cool that's
gonna be the future of gaming there is
the the crap you're gonna do postgame
with like your viewers yeah what do you
why do you want to call it there yeah
that's good I'm gonna move you into
place
[Music]
Hey hi folks I'm back in camera view
hopefully are you still going
I'm just moving around all right guys
I'm gonna go full camera thank you guys
all for tuning in as John Luke looks
like a fool right now stay tuned
tomorrow we're gonna do a destiny 2 dlc
curse of the ax cyrus that comes out
tomorrow if you guys want to we're
hoping around 10:00 is when maintenance
goes down and that's when we're
supposedly able to play if we can't play
at 10:00 I'll probably 11 we'll see
Wednesday we're gonna have our I think
it's our last episode of lobby is that
correct yeah our last episode of the
lobby for 2017 will be on Wednesday and
there will be more streams coming
Thursday Friday I think the game Awards
is also Thursday oh seven I think yes
yeah and then PSX is coming up this
weekend so be on the lookout for that
and as mentioned earlier our best of the
2017 is coming next week we'll be doing
our countdown of our top 10 games each
day we'll be reviewing different games
so 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 and then on the very
last day it'll be 3 2 & 1
so thank you guys all for tuning into
our doom VFR stream this was on psvr
it's currently out $29.99 if you guys
want to check that out
seems pretty good you can also buy the
gun if you want to the gun is $59.99 but
it still plays pretty well on controller
even more acted on Luke's getting tired
of looking around as I do this outro so
see you guys later bye bye oh he's back
he's back at normal reality wedding
always see you guys later thanks so much
don't
[Music]